féculent produits laitiers ou d'hygiène
des produits de première nécessité mais
aujourd'hui encore tout le monde n'y a
pas accès les restos du coeur lancent
leur 32e campagne hivernale dans ce
centre de la verrière 25 bénévoles
viennent en aide aux personnes en
difficulté
pour cette mère de famille c'est la
première fois qu'ils bénéficient de ce
soutien
gbc kocher seul un objectif la
nourriture c'est eux qui nous aider pour
faire comme il n'ya pas de travail on
travaille pas on vient ici nouveau c'est
qu'il y ait des traités c'est la
première fois que je viens ici on m'a
bien appuyé pour le moment le centre
compte une cinquantaine d'inscrits l'été
dernier il a enregistré une augmentation
de 9 % des bénéficiaires mères
célibataires familles dans le besoin et
étrangers sans ressources tous les
profils sont prises en charge
c'est là le profil si je veux dire la
typologie des personnes qu'on accueille
qui évolue un peu dans la mesure où on a
évidemment
des personnes
ce lent en demande d'asile par exemple
c'est sûr qu'on leur apporte un soutien
mais pas seulement alimentaire pas
seulement administratives pas seulement
vestimentaires c'est des gens qui
viennent ici pour parler pour rencontrer
l'hiver dernier le centre de la verrière
a aidé 114 familles les bénévoles en
attendent au moins autant la campagne
d'hiver va durer quatre mois l'an
dernier les restos du coeur ont
distribué plus de 130 millions de repas
dans toute la france